hey guys i'm here with my man max looga
beer and max you were on the reuben
report this week you've been on many
times before but you're doing something
very cool so I wanted to grab you for a
couple minutes you are doing a movie
that you are funding yourself you're
bringing crowdfunding right can we say
crowdfunding we could say crowdfunding
called breadhead which I'm going to let
you talk about but let's take a quick
look at Brad head and then we'll get
into it lacks changes in the brain begin
30 years before the first symptom so
that's why I'm here shooting this video
asking you to co-create with me a
documentary to take a journey to the
cutting edge of neuroscience along the
way we're going to challenge some very
commonly held assumptions that we make
about what constitutes a healthy diet we
know that whole grains are a key player
in healthy six to 11 servings per day is
what we need just like the gasoline for
the human body all to figure out whether
or not America's most feared disease is
inevitable or avoidable based on choices
that we make all right so fill me in a
little more on what bread head is all
about yeah so um about three years ago
my mom started showing signs of
cognitive difficulty and you know she's
currently 62 years old three years ago
she was 59 and without sort of any prior
family history of dementia it literally
That moment when I sort of had to come
to terms with the idea that something
was going on with my mom's cognition as
somebody who's obsessed with science and
health and nutrition I mean we've had so
many of these conversations about you
know nutrition and science and whatnot
it sent me down the rabbit hole to try
to figure out ways that I could not only
help her and try to sort of come to some
kind of understanding about what would
lead a health-conscious woman at 59 to
start experiencing you know signs of
early memory loss but then also how I
might prevent it in myself I mean you
know we're both creative guys you know
we um you know use our minds as part of
our our profession so the idea of like
one day becoming demented to me is like
an unfathomable fate and so breadhead
really is like the manifestation of all
of these findings and and really it's
ultimately like my way of just sort of
getting to talk to leaders in the field
to really get answers on this on this
epidemic yeah all right so you chose the
name breadhead so first off we got to
talk about huh bread for a second
now we're in LA everyone hates bread in
LA but I don't think it has anything to
do with memory that has to do probably
with wanting six-packs and stuff like
that but should people fear bread well I
think the reason why we call the film
bread head is because bread is the
ultimate example in my opinion of a
highly processed food masquerading as
like a healthy dietary staple I mean
when I think like healthy whole grains
which is what we've been told to believe
is super healthy to consuming copious
amounts I think of a slice of whole
wheat you know Brett is something that
that is good for you whole wheat it
sounds good Oh a new person yeah yeah
but when you look closer um bread has a
higher glycemic index than table sugar
so the glycemic index is a metric by
which carbohydrates it's the metric by
which they're judged in how they affect
your blood sugar and so it would be very
counterintuitive to believe that you
know a slice of whole wheat bread
affects your blood sugar more profoundly
than crystalline table sugar but it does
it's also America's number one source of
dietary sodium which was it was found to
be in 2012 by the CDC dietary sodium of
course many people can contribute type
retention which is a contributor to
vascular dementia which is the second
most common form of dementia after
alzheimer's and then it has gluten which
i know a lot of people are like
scratching their heads wondering what
gluten is should they consume it if
they're not celiac but um we're really
at the sort of cutting edge of science
now as it pertains to the interplay
between our gut health and our brain
health and gluten definitely and many
people has an impingement on gut health
which can have you know an implication
on brain over right so I'm big on all
the stuff and every time I've had you on
the show I try to do stories on this on
diets and the types of food that we can
eat that are proper and you know they're
just that we source food from thousands
of miles away and we don't eat local
stuff and then that hurts the economy
like there's there's so much to this and
you're doing this for a very personal
reason so how is uh I guess how's your
mom is that going to be part of this is
that going to be sort of yeah I mean
definitely I when I first started you
know I da ting over how I wanted bread
had to look and feel I
initially I think trying to like go a
supersize me route you know because
obviously that's a film that I saw many
years ago and as a documentary filmmaker
you know I loved it and obviously
working in Hollywood you're trained to
sort of look for successful formulas
tweak them a little bit and then call
them your own so I was like trying to
come up with a gimmick you know a way
for me to sort of undergo a special diet
and measure my cognition but um but
people started to listening to me I felt
like the most when I would start talking
about my own story the fact that this is
all motivated by the fact that like my
mom is actually going through this right
and I'm actually really looking for
answers so that I can help her mm-hmm
and also of course because you know if I
can make take steps today to ensure that
i will have a more optimal mind yeah and
I'm going to take those steps so that's
when I realized that that that's what
the story is yeah breadhead story to me
going on this journey to figure out you
know the best way to live to minimize
risk right so I don't want to give away
the whole thing now because we want this
to be fully made and fully funded but
let's just talk a little bit more about
the foods that you can eat that you
believe or that the science proves is
good for your cognition and to fight
some this stuff off so coconut oil which
I talk about all the time and I'm doing
that grass-fed butter and my coffee
coconut oil but love the real coffee
thing which I absolutely love what what
are the other couple other good foods if
people want to sort of guard their brain
health great question I mean I'm a big
fan of green tea green tea at least in
animals has been shown to disrupt the
major pathologies of Alzheimer's disease
it also boosts your working memory and
has a potent neurotropic which is like a
compound that affects brain brain
function positively called theanine
which promotes relaxation and stuff like
that so all around I think green tea is
an amazing thing to consume dark
chocolate has been shown to be really
good for brain health the flavanols the
dark chocolate can be very beneficial I
think it's it's avocado avocado because
we got it out that was great there was a
study recently that showed that avocado
had a really good effect on blood lipids
which is which is also important so I
macado's great I mean we have to
remember that the brain is made of fat
so we've been told for decades to avoid
fat right low fat and that's like the
key to health but um when you realize
that the brain is
sixty percent of fat and despite making
up only two to three percent of your
body's mass sequester is twenty-five
percent of your body's cholesterol I
mean the fact that we vilified fat and
cholesterol clear like it doesn't take a
neuroscientist to realize that that's
good potentially could have an
impingement on brain yeah so that's the
crazy thing so everyone is obsessed with
fat and they really don't understand
that there are good fats like you're
getting in these in grass-fed butter and
in coconut oil which has a lot of
calories and people think that that's
automatically bad but actually in this
case it's not yeah I mean a cow I would
recommend you know anybody that's really
interested in this as it pertains
especially to weight loss to check out
the work of Gary Taubes who wrote good
calories bad calories why people get fat
but coconut oil I mean it's amazing what
the you know the potential that coconut
oil has in terms of being therapeutic
for people with these sorts of diseases
they found so coconut oil is very high
in a medium chain triglycerides that's a
kind of fat that is found in abundance
in coconut oil and it sort of provides
ketones to the brain which are an
alternate and cleaner burning fuel
source to those brain cells that they
found to be deprived of glucose do to
you know any multitude of factors
whether it's you know insulin resistance
so they've they've done studies where
they've shown that people with higher
levels of ketones brought into the body
through the medium chain triglycerides
have better levels of cognition and
that's something that like you can get
easily by consuming coconut oil yeah
he's coconut oil the you know the thing
that's being studied no because it's not
something that can be patented and so
there's all these like reasons why right
but I think that it's worth a shot for
anybody for sure yeah so obviously your
goal with this is that you want to have
this made just so people can find out
more hopefully take some of the power
back to themselves so tell the good
people how they can help you fund this
whole operation yeah so go to red head
movie com that's where you'll you know
that will redirect to the crowdfunding
campaign link to do check out the full
video you can contribute definitely
sharing it on Facebook which drives a
lot of traffic I mean that would be
awesome and continue to tweet out the
link we've had like awesome traction so
far but we still have a really long way
to go so but you're pretty close you're
pretty close so take a look and thank
you max and yeah good luck I think it's
gonna be great thanks